so maybe there is a little bubble but in
the end of the day there's so many
companies they all of them are selling
something um so i don't think i think
the bubble that's going to explode is
actually of the people who's not aware
not dealing with the cyber attack in the
companies
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
episode is powered by j ventures a
community-driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about cyber security with umri segev
moyal the ceo of profero
omri is a highly successful entrepreneur
nationally recognized speaker and as of
recently a forbes 30 under 30 achiever
he is also the co-founder of profero
omri's passion for empowering others
through public speaking stems from the
many years of experience building
successful companies of his own he is
dedicated to sharing his knowledge and
proven skills with others in hopes that
he can provide them with simple
solutions that can solve complex
problems and help to remove any barriers
that stand in their way
his intense focus and drive for success
has positioned him to be one of the top
thought leaders in the entrepreneurial
and startup space
[Applause]
sega
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me today thank you
michael i'm really happy and honored to
be here i'm i'm so excited because you
know you're taking something that i
spent quite a few years in cyber
security and and you're literally facing
this this world
and what i think is probably the most
interesting part of the cyber security
space which is the actual incident
response you know we work tirelessly on
this cat and mouse game but at the end
of the day hits the fan something
happens and then the question is okay
what do we do now right and we don't
talk about that enough we don't hear
about that enough and so in these 20
minutes
i want to first understand you know your
you and your perspective in the
cyberspace why you went into incident
response and then try to figure out how
do companies actually react in these
situations and how do you with your
company help them get through it so omri
thank you for coming
share with me a little bit about
yourself and why cyber
cool so why cyber it's actually going
before it was called cyber i think it
was called maybe information security um
i started quite early around 12
my grandfather was which was a
retirement from the idf uh retired from
the idf he at the age of 60ish plus
decided he was really good at math and
he decided that computers are the next
big thing and i'm going to teach all my
grandsons uh granddaughters uh
everything i can about computers so he
self
self taught himself he learned how to
program things like pascal and c etc and
he bought
every
uh
granddaughter or grand
grandson uh he bought a computer
so it's actually divided half of us are
technophobical hate computers don't want
to touch an iphone or an on android and
the other half just
super in love with anything related to
tech so it's like either you push them
too hard and they didn't want it and
they hate it or it's something we all do
and i was pretty much into it pretty
young age
i am dyslexic so uh it actually really
helped me when i was young really really
helped
i'm i i spend most of my childhood
either outside making problems or on the
computer i almost barely went to school
i'm a dropout
uh i don't even have a bagrut i'm not
sure
yeah it's you know like it's like you
didn't you didn't finish 12th grade
right you didn't take yes
nothing uh so i didn't do all of that
but i either self-taught myself a lot of
other stuff
and
or just went outside with a lot of you
know pranks and like nothing illegal but
you know just a kid uh having a lot of
free time not going to school uh so
what how was your family at that point
you know you're obviously you know
you're such a curious person and in a
second you're going to be sharing with
me the way that you're helping you know
work through the most complicated
scenarios in the world
and yet you're not finishing high school
and you're doing pranks well how you
know there's a quite a big dissonance
here you know when i was young some
people said it's a lost course and i
don't know what we're going to do with
him but my parents were pretty much
listen it's probably because it's this
is selective it doesn't feel comfortable
at school let's not push and let's make
sure it just doesn't go anything illegal
he doesn't do anything
bad and let the kid live now whether
they were right or wrong i know it's
almost like flipping a coin i think what
they did and i fell on the right side
that i can't wait more credit than that
yeah
that's the way i still feel about it
today
um i don't know if i will raise my
children the same but it does
at least
looking like backward in time it does
feel a bit like that um
you know i could have done a lot of
other things and ended up in a whole
different place but you know it worked
well it's hard to judge you know what i
mean uh 100 100
so
i i want to jump to understanding a
little bit better you know within cyber
they you know so you you get into it
great but incident response how do you
get into that realm because you've done
quite a few things in the cyberspace
yeah cool so
one of my first
rodeo in actual cyber security was my
own company called snagbite and we
basically did some kind of what it's
called today threat intelligence bot
hunting which is basically trying to be
proactive monitoring hackers
it wasn't called exactly like that in
the day but this is what it was um
and at certain point
it was
all on me i had around five employees
and i felt that it's too much for me at
that point of time i was around 23 24
and i said listen it's too much
so i joined a bigger company called
clear sky and kliska had it was a
service company and it had a lot of
customers and right from the start the
thing i found myself and i always did i
did that in the army and i did it you
know when i was younger i'm really good
on the stress and under when everybody
is crying and running out and there's a
lot of pressure this is where i work the
best it's just i don't know why and how
i got to be like that but
if it's boring or
being static this is actually where i'm
not good at when there's a lot of
advantage a lot of pressure i thrive so
it was really easy for me to be pushed
for an instant response that's how i got
into it
and i realize i'm
i might be okay in that field like i'm
actually enjoying the stress i'm
enjoying the atmosphere
uh following that i
i founded a company called mineoverlabs
which is kind of like if i'm not
pushing it too technical some kind of a
next-gen
malware prevention system
i was the head of research there
but also in minerva
i
also been really drawn to the incidents
the big incidents that we have in the
largest customers for example one of
them was the very notorious case of city
of atlanta
i think it was in 2017 if i'm not
mistaken or to i know since covered
everything has become
hard to go back in time and went what
year was it uh but i think was 2017 or
17.
and i was really drawn into that
so i knew right from the start the next
thing i'm going to do and when i'm doing
something is going to be an instant
response and when i left me never i was
just you know
really into it and
and there's a lot of work in our field
it's just uh instant response for people
who is not aware what it is
uh it's basically when an organization
an enterprise a company or even vips or
personal people
get in any kind of way from you know
wire transfer fraud to run somewhere uh
denial of service attacks a lot of any
hack
uh instant response the general term of
the team or whoever helps you solve the
case uh this is how it calls for cyber
incident response i think that it's it's
it's a very interesting inflection point
right now because there's the common
question at least in the israeli
ecosystem are we in a bubble right is
this a cyber bubble and my immediate
thinking says well there's only one way
to check let's look at the incidents
that are happening right but but but
people don't really talk about the
incidents that are happening and it's
and i can only imagine that
the companies often have the most
incentive to quiet down the incidents
right and so you have this dissonance
between
you know people who understand the
industry that they're working tirelessly
like you to prevent the incidents and to
tackle them there's the incidents that
are happening that people don't really
hear about and then there's everybody
else who doesn't really who's not
involved in this thing and saying like
why is everybody work talking about this
if it's not happening
is it happening is it a common thing
that's happening
so there's a sentence uh
it was said in it's really famous in the
wall street bets and they said whenever
someone says it's a bubble they said
it's a boomer wall it's a boomer wall
and i think it's the same listen
i know they saying there's a huge bubble
around cyber
i let down uh every so every customer i
take free we have to let down because we
don't have enough resources we're still
expanding we keep expanding and
expanding so
you might say
bubble but look we have companies that
you know our company was emerged two
years ago we're already selling over 4
million are uh in revenue and we are
fully bootstrapped i don't know many
fields where it would have done the same
uh look at tweeze everybody's speaking
you know oh it's a big bubble company
they have almost 30 million er in i
don't know one year and a half two years
um so maybe there is a little bubble but
in the end of the day there's so many
companies they all of them are selling
something um so i don't think i think
the bubble that's going to explode is
actually of the people who's not aware
not dealing with the cyber attack in the
companies and how it's exploding it's
not going to be some huge market bubble
that everybody's going to suffer it's
going to be very personal to either your
own computers or your own organization
and this is what we see those small
well huge bubble personal bubbles though
are exploding people are almost losing
their businesses i can't count the many
the amount of times i got to
organization and they're nearly off the
verge of crying i'm literally crying
because
they're either going to close their
business if they don't do things right
um i for example we have a
factory that we assisted uh pro bono we
got a call from them they said listen uh
we're already in so much that we have no
money to pay you if i don't get
recovered in 48 hours i'm just shutting
down my own life business and we're like
okay listen
will help and and we managed it was hard
uh but we managed so these are the
bubbles that we're going to explode and
i don't think the stock exchange cyber
companies bubble is going to be i
yeah i mean i think you know i'll allow
myself to say my own two cents about you
know this idea of the bubble i mean at
the end we're talking about
you know a lot of people are trained to
look at the world today and say does
this make sense today
but at the end you know you're saying
that you're saying this from the inside
right and you're saying what's happening
and where you know together we the two
of us can experience you know the growth
of the opportunities for for cyber
defense and offense and it's becoming
scary right every time we talk about
digitalization of anything
you and i can think of okay there's well
here are the million other ways that
this thing can be exploited which makes
room for companies like perfero but it
also makes room for for big valuations
and for big opportunities for companies
like quiz and the likes
what happens in an incident
how does an incident happen who
discovers it
you know it's a big question but walk me
through sort of this journey that you're
on
let me tell you a story uh i can't name
you know the companies etc but uh
let's
look back a certain point of time it's
somewhere between around april
the whole world is on the lockdown of a
strange covered virus coveted 19. nobody
really know what it is
and you you are the administrator of a
company in hong kong
if you remember what happened in hong
kong and april people couldn't even
leave the house there were riots because
the uh chinese administration riots uh
etc
and you get a call from one of your
business admin hey whatever his name i
can't access anything it's like okay i'm
at my home i can't do anything and he's
trying to access and only thing he gets
in the end is a one system all the web
servers are down the entire organization
is down and all he gets from remote is a
message saying listen your files and
everything is under ransom
pay us
a lot of money with eight million
dollars
or
um or suffer the consequences we're
going to leak all your diet oh my god
they can't even drive to the data center
because of the lockdown to risk like to
even even put new servers not even let's
say we don't care about the incident
think how devastative it is for the
business they are a way they are remote
we are a company that baseball we have
people all over the world with people in
new zealand with people in the u.s but
in the end of the day we all live in the
cyberspace doesn't matter we are a fully
remote company
we can't reach hong kong even if we
really wanted to
we can't log in into the systems because
the attackers actually
gain control
what do you do in this type of of case
this is one of the only times we have
used actually offensive capabilities
to get back in the servers the actors
attacked game control
now look at how many things you need to
take care of first of all i need to
verify somehow that a person in hong
kong i'm speaking to actually owns that
system
it may be someone pulling a prank on us
or the really illegal right so that's
number one number two i need to pray god
that we actually have the right
offensive capabilities and you know we
to actually gain control and then i need
to kick out the attackers and give the
real people back access
in the end of the day in this specific
case actually run some more space um in
the end of the day even though we kicked
the attackers the best for the
organization to get back during that
time and not lose the entire business
was to pay ransom so you go to sleep one
night
uh you care of your family you know you
collect a lot of food and stuff that
will happen in april and you wake up in
the morning where
you know there's riots in the street and
you need to drive to a data center and
try to get
that's how hard cyber attacks can be
now moving forward to 2021 almost 2022
coffee is a bit more relaxed people can
leave the house you know it's still
dangerous and everything i'm not putting
anything you know uh not down playing
coffee but
you still can wake up and not having
control over your own business or
even an ancient state like that there is
some cases where everyone
nations they decide to target your small
little business
maybe you sell clothes for example and
they just target you because they want
to shame your country and they will lick
all your data run some all your files
now
what are you doing these type of things
like most people
don't know what to do both business also
tech it's not something you usually deal
with there's a lot of panic
there's a lot of bad choices
and this is this time usually when
people call us
and that's where we get involved that's
where our team
putting all the relaxation putting all
of our experience to first
handle the situation at the best way
possible during that very stressful time
getting the customers out of that
situation
and after the incident making sure it
doesn't happen again to them so become
do people prefer work you know the nine
to seven nine to eight hours how does it
work because you know i'm getting you
could get a call at 10 p.m and say
listen you know we need to pay ransom
within 24 hours or we're get or they're
going to leak the credit card numbers on
our system
you're you're the ceo of this thing
right you're the entrepreneur you're the
leader
obviously have a very talented team with
you but they have lives as well how do
you manage this whole thing
so at the start it was really hard
because you know it wasn't many of us
and it was
24 7 doing everything you know and with
all the people we had but as the company
grow we have people from all over the
world we
we call it like people used to call it
follow the sun i don't really like that
um there but we basically have people
everywhere for example the actual day
started in new zealand uh it's 11 hours
different from israel so it's whenever
they have daylight we have you know uh
we're we are during our night etc we
have people from the us we have people
from india we have people from england
so it's not really 24 7 because you do
your usual day work
the benefit from it is first we have
really good capable people all over the
world and second when you finish your
day someone else
start of the day or at least halfway
through and then someone else's start of
the day and therefore
although it's really tricky business and
it's people really under stress
for us it's a day-to-day work so in the
end of the day people are used to
shifting over
even if it's a very major incident we
can shift it over to the next crew etc
so we're actually dealing with it like a
normal day work
and then weekends as well we do like
normal shifts between same ways
production team are doing shifts et
cetera what are you enjoying well it's
becoming very interesting field of work
is it the the excitement of a new case
sort of like a sherlock holmes is it the
leadership part of it
is it the technology part of it
i think not just myself but the entire
company even people from the dev and
business and the office admins
i think the best thing is the feedback
we get from customers and it's not that
the feedback you will see on a message
freaking out that was deployed the best
ever and you know we
i i i can't really show yours or you
know we don't have testimonials because
it's not something we want to share with
the public because but
it's you saved my business
um
you i was i was gonna jump out of the
roof and whatever you did is just magic
uh you know people
the way we get yeah we're getting
standing presents
uh we're getting setting a lot of things
after and you know i've been to many
companies before i never had that very
very emotional
i think doctors might have gotten into
that you are a doctor you know feedback
in a larger way your tech is amazing or
you know i wouldn't make myself a doctor
essentially uh but but
i it it is the same feeling
yeah it is the same feeling and you know
especially if you do pro bono cases and
stuff like that it's it's really really
emotional um on the other side what
keeps our living it's you know building
a bigger company yeah um leaving the
tech side and being a ceo it's one of
the only challenging you know for me
almost the daily most companies they
create products that are sold when other
companies do well right most sas
products most things that you get that
you that most tech companies that are
building are built for so that the
successful companies pay
you know to become more successful here
you're saying we're building a product
that
you know we we that when the company is
most distressed when they need us most
that's when we're there we're at the
lowest point and and i think that's
awesome i think that's a really really
awesome place to be at and and as a
future entrepreneur and a as a thinker i
i get inspired by
you know this type of company and by
your work and the stories and and you
know i'm sure we can talk about this for
hours but but i want to thank you for
being here and for sharing this time
with me and and i can't wait to share
this with with my friends with my family
this is such an exciting journey that
you're on so thank you only thank you
very much
[Music]
you